countering the Queens can be declined
most popular trap is always a fun thing
and we are going to witness one of them
in this video
fasten up your seat belt guys as you are
going to witness
one of the most amazing counter trap in
the qgd exchange
from the black perspective
[Music]
the critical position arises after the
falling opening mortar
D4 D5 C4 E6 Knight to C3 Knight to F6
now white Exchange in the center with C
capsules D5 e captures D5
and Bishop to G5 pressurizing the D Pawn
okay the main line continues with Bishop
to E7 E3 and after black Castle White
plays this very cunning move Bishop to
D3
setting up a nasty opening trap
and in fact many black players has
fallen for this as if you look at the
database here
there are more than 6000 games continue
with the move B6 which I'm afraid a big
time disaster for the black as white can
now execute one of the most popular trap
in this line
starting with
Bishop takes F6
Bishop takes F6 and now this lovely move
Queen to H5 which not only threatened on
at seven are Checkmate but it's also
attacking on D5 and unfortunately for
black he cannot defend both of this
thing
so for example after G6 Queen captures
D5
black is forced to exchange the queen
and the end result is white become Pawn
up in just 11th move of the game
so this is one of the high profile trap
in the qgd which you should definitely
watch out from both the colors
now imagine my surprise that is Rook to
E8
and not only this move handle the Trap
but surprisingly it can create a
wonderful counter trap
which is in fact some strong players has
fallen for it
so if you are a white here you think
hang on that doesn't make any difference
I can go with the same line right
so Bishop takes F6 Bishop takes F6
Queen to H5 same old story you attacking
the two spots so black response is force
he has to play G6
and what else
Queen captures D5 once again winning the
pawn
and asking black are you interested in
the early resignation
hahaha
well after Black's next reply I think it
is white who get the root shock
did you spot it
yup this amazing move Bishop captures D5
boom
boom so now not only black has regained
his material back
but he has a very simple threat namely
Bishop capture C3 and nabbing the queen
something which white need to address
immediately
now as per the database there are two
popular choices here number one Knight G
to E2 number two queen captures d8
well the first move Knight E2 I'm afraid
very bad and after this black is winning
on the spot
by going through this simple sequence
Queen captures D5
Knight captures D5
and now you straight away go into the
complication with Bishop captures B2
white doesn't have time to defend this
Rook as after Rook to B1 we can play
Bishop to E5 and black is coming out as
a clear Pawn advantage
so no white has to go for the Tactical
battle Knight capture C7
now you take the rook in the corner
whereupon white has two choices
if we continue with the bad move Knight
captures E8 then after Bishop to E5
black has closed all the doors for that
white night
and after the only forcing reply F4
we can make this simple transaction King
to fade Pawn takes IFA and King captures
E8
yes
at the end the material is balanced but
I can surely tell you that double e Pawn
can hardly survive in such end games
so that is the reason why Knight
captures E8 is a pretty bad move
what about Knight captures E8
well this time around we have the same
story Bishop to E5
blocking the Escape Route
and after some accurate sequence
Castle on the king's side
Bishop to D7
Rook to be one attacking on B7
Bishop to C6
white should try to eliminate this
bishop by playing Knight to D4 and
accordingly black shouldn't allow it
and lopital
so that after e captures D4
we can simply play Rook to C8 and the
threat is very obvious B6 and taking
down that Knight
well to avoid it white has the only good
move here namely Rook to C1
but the chess engine suggest here that
black should play Rook to d8 allowing
this Knight to come out but in return
get the very important Pawn
which is more than enough to secure a
full point
so this is how black should respond if
white continue with Knight G to E2
well by far the most popular choices
Queen captures d8
but exactly here black reveal his
amazing Trump that is Bishop capture C3
Pawn capture C3 and now taking this
queen
whereupon the end result is
yup we have a balanced material but
white has some fractured Pawn on the
queen side
and you might think well that's not a
big deal white can easily play around
with it
but nope
the more you analyze this position more
you will come to know that it is pretty
difficult for white to even continue
well from this position
for example I can show you a model game
where a 2600
goes down the hill very quickly from
this position
he played King to E2 defending the
bishop
black plays Bishop to E6
pressurizing day two Pawn so The Rook
has been tied down
and after Knight to F3 black plays this
nice accurate move Knight to D7
and I think white is already fed up with
defending the pawn
so he played A4 at this point which is
turned out as a big time disaster as
after Black's next Moon Knight to C5
more or less white cat a disgusting
position
well you can't defend with either of the
Rook as after Knight captures D3 and
Rook captures D3 black can create this
important pin which wins The Exchange
so by force white has to move the bishop
but that just simply allow this check
and after King to even
already white Rooks are disconnected
well I really like how quickly black
finished the white as he continued with
another favorable exchange namely Bishop
to D3
and after Bishop takes and Rook takes
why to his horror find out that he's
about to lose a vital Pawn
and even Rook to A3 it doesn't solve the
mystery as just one move Knight to E4
and indeed white lost the pawn and in
fact the gay
so if a 2600 plus rated player
struggling like this imagine
how good these positions are for the
black camp
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile counter trap in
the qgd which you can set up by playing
this cunning move Rook to E8 and if
white thinks that you are a complete
idiot and goes with the sequence that is
Bishop takes up six Bishop takes F6 and
queen to H5 winning a very important
deep on
but the matter of fact is after Bishop
captures default it is white who is
going to struggle for the rest of the
game
and in fact there are few very rare
lines like this where just within the
opening stage
black get a necking age
so I hope you really try this counter
trap in your game
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
buy and take care